turning back now to the death of 20 year
old dante wright in the brooklyn center
in minnesota
in brooklyn center minnesota that's the
name of the town tragedy with too many
parallels
in our recent past it was six years ago
yesterday
that freddie gray was fatally hurt in
the back of a police van that story
happened in baltimore
prosecutors say he had just told an
officer i can't breathe
just that eric garner had done the year
before and just as george floyd did in
his last moments alive
in may of 2020. in the book five days
the fiery reckoning of an american city
now out in paperback author wes
moore recounts the events surrounding
freddie freddie gray's death
it's a book he wrote with journalist
erica green and moore says the time
is now to ask how much have we learned
and we should point out he is also
ceo of the robin hood foundation one of
the nation's largest anti-poverty
non-profits
and he joins us now on cbs this morning
wes good morning to you
your day job at robin hood foundation
and your work as an author they actually
intersect poverty and racism are related
and i want to get to that but first you
raise the question
what have we learned in the years since
freddie gray i'd love you to answer it
well the the honest answer is is not
enough because
you know we we look at the fact that
this book is coming out now and people
say well isn't it timely
that the paperback of five days is
coming out now and the honest question
the honest answer is
name a time when it wouldn't have been
timely uh that's the issues is that we
keep on seeing these things that are
that are that are happening
and so this really is both about how are
we addressing the
uh immediate incidents that we continue
to see uh the the the death of
of of mr right is is not just
unfortunate it is inhumane and it needs
to be dealt with
uh but we also have to understand the
structural challenges that we continue
to see that allow these incidents to
continue to happen and just new names
being placed after hashtags yeah so wes
what happens next
what do we do to break this cycle to
start working on that underlying system
that you described so well
in the afterward of this book
well i think we need to have a very
coordinated conversation and coordinated
action plan
that includes community that includes
law enforcement
that includes actually changing policies
and laws
you know we look at in my home state of
maryland where we just actually had a
police reform bill that
was uh was was actually vetoed by a
republican governor but overturned by 70
percent of the legislature
which puts together common sense laws
you know such as that you know making
body cameras mandatory for police
knowing that if a police officer
who has multiple infractions uh is
getting moved to different departments
that those new departments that they're
going to should know about them
you know basic common sense things that
we all know have to be dealt with with
with actually not just dealing with
improper interaction between policing
and community but actually really
fostering a better relationship
between police and community as well
yeah when you talk about improper
interaction i keep thinking about dante
wright we've been talking about it all
morning it started as a traffic stop
because of expired tags allegedly they
found out that he had a misdemeanor
outstanding warrant and it escalated
from there but the bottom line is he was
unarmed and the
police officer said she thought she had
a taser that she was using her taser
instead of a gun
you're a military guy wes when you hear
that what do you think
i am i i'm baffled honestly because you
know
if someone hit i have so much training
in this that if someone hands me
a weapon i can tell whether it's loaded
or unloaded
you know i can tell a caliber that's how
much training that i have
in in in march and ship and arms because
they knew that they were trusting me to
go out
and make life-or-death decisions every
single day
you know there's something in the
military that we call muscle memory
where basically
we want you to do things enough that in
high stress situations
that there isn't a question you just
know properly how to respond
and the idea that you could not tell the
difference
or maybe could make a quick reaction
difference between a firearm
and a taser means there was not enough
training or preparation for you to be
able to handle either
of those devices and you know what's
interesting that's the thing that really
hurts
she's a training officer she was
training a rookie that day that's
that's what i find so mind-boggling but
let's talk about freddie gray because
we all remember this case i remember you
you freddie grace from baltimore you're
from baltimore
you said that freddie gray was the first
funeral that you went to from someone
that you didn't know and that we really
should pay attention to freddie gray's
life why did you go to his funeral and
what was his life that you wanted us to
know about him
you know i went to freddie's funeral
because i i felt
it was it was a story that i had both a
local connection with you know this is a
really big deal
in baltimore and also around the globe
and so i wanted to pay final respects
but it also did really strike me gail
the fact that
you know i was sitting here at a funeral
of someone who i did not know
in life and that was part of the problem
most of the people inside the church
that day did not ever have a single
conversation with freddie and when you
look at freddie's life
if you look at the fact that this was a
young man who was born
premature and underweight it was a young
man who was born into deep poverty
his mother lived in deep poverty her
entire life she couldn't she never made
to high school she couldn't read or
write
you know she was also battled addiction
for much of her life
and so when freddie was born he was
already exposed to heroin
when they moved out of when he gained
enough weight to go out of the hospital
they moved into a housing project in
west baltimore and that home
along with 480 other homes in 2009
were cited in a civil lawsuit because of
the endemic levels of lead
inside of that home so freddie gray was
born underweight
premature exposed to heroin
born into deep poverty and lead poisoned
and by that time in his life he's two
years old
if you look at why he was even arrested
that day he was arrested for making
eye contact with police in a high
poverty area which in only some areas of
this country
is a crime and that's the issue
and that is the intersection of poverty
and race you say that each of these
circumstances increases the probability
that he's in that place
at that time and at one point in one of
the most powerful sentences in the book
you make the point that the system in
some communities is its own kind of
chokehold
but but while we have you because you're
a veteran and because we've been
reacting to that video out of virginia
with the lieutenant pulled from his
vehicle and pepper sprayed
what was your reaction what's going
through your mind as you watch that
whoa hold on absolute horror
and it's horror in the fact that you
know everything that
that that i was taught and told
everything that i know i but i have a
seven-year-old son
uh and and i will i will express to him
that if you happen to have an
interaction with police
you know keep your hands in clear sight
uh you know don't make quick movements
call them sir you know and you show that
all these things to include what car
you're driving your cv
your resume uh the uniform you were
wearing
it did not matter and in fact every time
he tried to
try to say i don't understand or what or
his response when he said i'm afraid to
leave the vehicle
the officer's response back to him was
you should be yeah
that's that's the thing i mean that
alone exactly that alone
is is is is an entirely offense it
certainly did strike me wes because
every parent i know every black parent
of color i don't care if you have two
dollars or you have
two two million dollars has had the
conversation with their sons about this
is what you do if you're stopped by the
police
and he did everything correctly and
still still ended up
ended up that way i'm so glad he's alive
but i can't imagine the trauma that
lieutenant is feeling
today it's heartbreaking to me but
before we go we have to ask you about
this
when do we start covering when when do
we start calling you i don't want to
stumble on this
gubernatorial candidate wes moore when
should we start doing that
well i'm i'm very seriously exploring
the the governor's race in maryland
right now as i as i'm
you know getting ready to exit uh four
and a half really proud and successful
years at robin hood
the reality is is that we are at a we
are at a turning point and there are
really big
crucial issues that we have to discuss
and so as i'm as i'm really going
through and thinking about what are the
big
solutions our ability to think big on
these issues i think is now and so it is
something that i am very seriously
exploring
as i'm getting ready to uh to step away
from my role ceo all right
wes moore will be watching when you're
ready to announce you know you have a
place
this morning with tony decouple anthony
mason and gayle king we thank you very
much
five days is out now in paperback
wherever you like to buy your books